foreign
I'm honored to welcome you back to the
White House
we spent an awful lot of time on the
telephone
as well as on video but it's good to see
him first again
and uh
we've been in close and frequent
communication throughout this conflict
from the very beginning but particularly
uh is particularly meaningful to talk
with another in person look each other
in the eye
because leadership through this terrible
crisis has inspired the Ukrainian people
as you have done Mr President Dan the
American people and the entire world
this visit to Washington your first trip
outside Ukraine since February comes as
President Putin has escalated his
attacks his brutal attacks
targeting critical infrastructure to
make life as hard as possible
for not only Innocent ukrainians but
children and young children everything
from orphanages to schools it's just
outrageous what he's doing
and we've uh as we've heard into the as
we head in the New Year it's important
for the American people and for the
world to hear directly from you Mr
President about Ukraine's fight and the
need to continue to stand together
through 2023.
this visit also falls on the 300-day
mark of Russia's brutal invasion of
Ukraine
300 days since Putin launched an
unprovoked unjustified all-out assault
on the Free People of Ukraine
300 days of Ukrainian people showing
Russia and the world they're still
backbone their love of country and their
unbreakable determination and I
emphasize unbreakable determination to
choose their own path
to Ukrainian people
I say to them all you have demonstrated
you've shown your strong stand against
aggression in the face of the Imperial
appetites of autocrats who wrongfully
believe you might you might they might
be able to make might right and they're
not able to do it thus far they've not
they've stood alone
you know and you've have but you haven't
stood alone you have had significant
significant help we've never stand alone
you will never stand alone when
Ukraine's Freedom was threatened the
American people like Generations
Americans before us did not hesitate
the support from all across this country
Americans of every Walk of Life
Democrats and Republicans alike had the
resources and the to rebound and
resounding United Way to to provide
unequivocal and unbending support for
Ukraine because we understand in our
bones that Ukraine's fight is part of
something much bigger the American
people know that if we stand by in the
face of such a blatant attacks on
Liberty and democracy and the core
principles of sovereignty and
territorial Integrity the world would
surely face worse consequences as I said
when Putin rolled his tanks in the
Ukraine in February American American
people are prepared to have us stand up
to bullies stand up for Freedom that's
who we are as Americans and that's
exactly what we've done
even before The Invasion began and Putin
threatened Ukraine by building up his
forces we helped make sure Ukraine would
be prepared to defend itself even before
they crossed into Ukraine we provide a
steady stream of defensive weapons
including air defense systems and
artillery ammunition and so much more
we've not done it alone from the very
beginning the United States rallied
allies and partners from around the
world to stand strong with Ukraine and
impose unprecedented and I emphasize
unprecedented sanctions and Export
controls on Russia making it harder for
the Kremlin to wage this brutal War
more than 50 Nations have committed
nearly 2 000 tanks and other armored
vehicles more than 800 artillery systems
more than two million rounds of
artillery ammunition and more than 50
Advanced multiple rocket launching
systems and I ship and anti and air
defense systems all to strengthen
Ukraine
together we provided billions of dollars
in direct budgetary support
to make sure the Ukrainian government
can keep providing basic fundamental
services to the Iranian people like
Health Care education and emergency
personnel
this includes another two billion
dollars that in direct budget support
from the American people at the World
Bank distributed earlier this week
we provide a humanitarian assistance to
help the millions of ukrainians who have
been forced to flee their homes because
of Putin's inhumane brutal War
communities across Europe have opened
their hearts and their homes to help
ukrainians in need
the United States has been proud to
welcome more than 221 thousand
ukrainians seeking Refuge since March of
2022 including as part of uniting for
Ukraine as part of our United Ukraine
program and today usaid is committing
more than 374 million dollars in
urgently humanitarian assistance for
Ukraine
this will help provide food and cash
assistance for more than 1.5 million
Ukrainian people as well as Access to
Health Care safe drinking water and help
stay warm in the winter to more than for
more than 2.5 million ukrainians the
United States and our allies and
partners around the world have delivered
a broad range of assistance at historic
speed and has been critical to
bolstering Ukraine's success thus far
Ukraine has won the Battle of Kiev has
won the Battle of Pearson has won the
Battle of kharkiv Ukraine has defied
Russia's expectations at every single
turn
foreign
you have made it clear that he is uh
open to pursuing uh
um well let me put it this way he's not
open but you're open to pursuing peace
you're open to pursuing a just peace we
also know that Putin has no intention no
intention of stopping this cruel War and
the United States is committed to
ensuring that the brave Ukrainian people
can continue continue to defend their
country against Russian aggressions as
long as it takes and I want to thank the
members of Congress and they're for the
broad bipartisan support to Ukraine and
I look forward to signing the Omnibus
Omnibus Bill soon which includes 45
billion dollars 45 billion dollars in
additional funding for Ukraine I'll also
sign in the law the National Defense
authorization Act which includes author
authorities for to make it easier for
the Department of Defense to procure
critical Munitions and defense materials
for Ukraine and other key materials to
strengthen our national security today
I'm announcing the next tranche of our
security assistance Ukraine
1.85 billion dollar package of security
assistance that includes both direct
transfers of equipment to you that
Ukraine needs as well as contracts to
supply ammunition Ukraine will need in
the months ahead for its artillery its
tanks and its rocket launchers
critically in addition to these new
capabilities like Precision aerial
Munitions the package will include a
patriot missile battery which will and
one which will train Ukrainian forces to
operate as part of the ongoing effort to
help bolster Ukraine's air defense
this could take some time to complete
the necessary training but the Patriot
battery will be another critical asset
for Ukraine as it defends itself against
Russian aggression
all together today's new security
assistance with humanitarian funding
amounts to 2.2 billion dollars in
Digital support for the Ukrainian people
we should be clear about what Russia is
doing
it is a purposefully attacking Ukraine's
critical infrastructure destroying the
system to provide heat and light to
Ukrainian people during the coldest
darkest part of the year
Russia is using winter as a weapon
freezing people starving people cutting
them off from one another
it's the latest example of the
outrageous atrocities the Russian forces
are committed against innocent Ukrainian
civilians children and their families
and the United States is working
together or their allies and partners to
provide critical equipment to help
Ukraine make emergency repairs to their
power transmission systems and
strengthen the stability of Ukraine's
Grid in the face of Russia's targeted
attacks we're also working to hold
Russia accountable including efforts in
Congress that will make it easier to
seek Justice for Russia's war crimes in
Ukraine
let me close with this
tonight is the fourth night the night of
Hanukkah a time when Jewish people
around the world president zielinski and
many of the families among them honored
the Timeless Miracle the small band of
warriors fighting for their values and
their freedom against a much larger Foe
and how they endured and how they
overcame
how the flame of Faith with only enough
oil for one day burned brightly for
eight days
The Story of Survival and resilience
that reminds us that the coldest days of
the year that light will always Prevail
over darkness and hope drives away
despair
and that the human spirit is
unconquerable as long as there are good
people willing to do what is right
this year has brought so much needless
suffering and loss to the Ukrainian
people
but I want you to know president
zielinski I want you to know that all
the people in Ukraine to know as well
the American people have been with you
every step of the way and we will stay
with you we will stay with you for as
long as it takes
what you're doing
what you've achieved it matters not just
to Ukraine but to the entire world and
together I have no doubt we'll keep the
flame of Liberty Burning Bright
and the light will remain and Prevail
over the darkness thank you for being
here Mr President we're going to stand
with you
thank you
Dear Mr President
please put on the equipment once again
Mr president President Biden audience
journalists ladies and gentlemen I came
here to the United States to forward it
thank the word of thanks to the people
of America people who do so much for
Ukraine I am thankful for all of this
this visit to the United States became a
really a historic one for our relations
with the United States and the American
leadership in the last 30 days of this
war we have started a new face of our
inter relations with the United States
we became a real
partners and allies with the content and
I felt today during all of my meetings
and during our talks once again I would
like to thank Mr President President
Biden for his candid support and what is
very important the understanding of
Ukraine and for the support of the
International Coalition to strengthen
international law I am grateful to
President Biden for his personal uh
efforts his steps that unite the
partners and Global South when all
countries of the world
take some position
and are focusing on cooperation and
mutual understanding this is very
useful for all of the countries for
Ukraine for the United States I want to
thank the Congress for bipartisan
bicameral support and uh I am looking
forward to good meetings with the
members of the Congress and their
support this is the visit that I am I'm
here today to meet with the Congress the
main issue during my today's talks is to
strengthen Ukraine next year our
movement forward to fight for our
freedom and Independence I have good
news returning home President Biden
announced a new package of Defense
support about 2 billion US Dollars and
the strongest element of this package is
the Patriots Battery Systems something
that will strengthen our air defense
significantly this is a very important
step
to create a secure airspace for Ukraine
and that's the only way we would be able
to deprive the terrorist country and
their terror attack to attack to strike
our energy sector our people and our
infrastructure we had a very good
negotiation and talks about our
strategic steps which we discussed with
President Biden and what we expect next
year and for what we are preparing this
is very important for all ukrainians and
I am hopeful and once again thank you Mr
President for 45 billion because this is
a big assistance and I hope that the
Congress will approve this financial
assistance for our crime country this is
almost 45 billion thank you very much
for the support every dollar of this
investment for the United States is
going to be strengthening of Global
Security I know that the American
leadership will be strong and will play
important role in global scope and the
United States will help us to defend our
values values and Independence and
regardless of changes in the Congress I
believe that there will be bipartisan
and bipart bicameral support and I know
that everybody works for this and of
course during all of my meetings today
we discussed issues of a standoff
against a terror of Russia their
destruction of our energy infrastructure
we need to survive this winter we need
to protect our people and we need to be
very specific in this area this is a key
humanitarian issue for us right now this
is the survival issue we are discussing
sanctions and legal pressure on the
terrorist country Russia Russia needs to
hold to be held accountable for
everything it does against us against
our people against Europe and the whole
free world and it is very important that
we have the peace formula and for that
we offer very specific steps what
America can do to help us to implement
them we propose Global formula for peace
Summit I'm thankful for our American
counterparts that they feel us and
understand how it's important it is to
continuance and stay on course and work
on
Integrity of the country and
international
rule of law we will also need as soon as
our defense capabilities will be
strengthened in the next few months I
don't want to discuss it in details
right now I believe you understand why
and I but I am very grateful to
President Biden thank you for your
attention to all of these issues glory
to Ukraine
thank you very much Mr President we're
going to take a questions from four
different reporters I'm going to start
with Alex of Yahoo news
thank you Mr President
um in 20 2022 you presided over a
bipartisan International Coalition to
support Ukraine how will you keep that
Coalition from fraying in 2023 and uh
president zielinski welcome to
Washington and this beautiful winter day
what is your message to the American
people
oh the answering your questions first uh
um I'm not at all worried about holding
the alliance
um that's uh
um
I assume this is simultaneous
all right
okay I've never seen NATO or the EU more
united about anything at all and I see
no sign of there being any change
we all know what's at stake here our
European Partners all the more so they
fully understand it this is about we've
never seen a major invasion of a
European country since World War II and
they see no signs that
Putin is going to do anything to change
that unless we resist and we help the
ukrainians resist we all know what's at
stake the very idea of sovereignty the
U.N Charter
Putin thought he would weaken NATO
instead he strengthened NATO I once said
to him that we talk about the he wanted
to see the uh you know Europe end up
being
divided uh the uh and instead what did
he do he produced a more united Europe
with Sweden and Finland joining so I
don't see any reason to believe there'll
be any less thing of support and as we
reach out to our NATO allies our
secretary of defense and the Secretary
of State we get continued support not
only there but also from around the
world from Japan and many other
countries as well so I feel very good
about the solidarity of support for
Ukraine
thank you for your question thank you
very much you asked me what are the
messages
I will tell you very simple things which
are very important for me
and I and I think so that we have
the same values and the same
understanding of the life
the sense of the life my message
I wish you peace
I think that is the main thing
and you understand it only when the war
in your country
when somebody like these terrorists from
Russia
come to your houses
and I wish you to see your children
alive
and adults
and I wish you to see your children and
they will go to university
and to see their children
I I think that is the main thing what I
can wish you
and of course to be together with us
generally
because we really fight for our common
Victory against this tyranny
that is real life
and we will win
and I really want
win together
thanks so much
not want sorry I'm sure
call on one of your people
depressed person yeah
yeah thank you let me try an option to
Ukrainian television oh President Biden
I got a question to both of you but
firstly as Ukrainian and I mean it I
want to thank United States for
supporting my country and you know my
family is in Ukraine and I definitely
understand there will not be alive today
if America will not support my country
both political and militarily so thank
you for this
and as of my question I will enter a new
phase of this war and uh you definitely
discussed today which path to choose uh
how the work could come to an end and
what's next will it turn into a new
counteroffensive or some kind of peace
talks so Mr Biden Mr zelensky could you
share your vision what's the fair way to
end this war and how do you understand
these words Fair peace thank you
my view you're a guy I think we have oh
yeah I see it I see although I like it
very much already
[Music]
you have started this question
I'm sorry sometimes I switch on my
native language
you have started by stating that your
family is in cave and without the
assistance of the United States
uh this is absolutely true the U.S
leadership in this assistance is
uh strong and uh again yeah I would like
to remind you that your family will be
in danger
uh without the Armed Forces of Ukraine
which is very important
that concerns your questions per se uh
what would you like to hear uh
uh just peace I don't know I don't know
what just this is it's a very
philosophical description if there is a
just War I don't know
um you know for all of us peace
just peace is different for me as a
president just peace is no compromises
as to the sovereignty freedom and
territorial Integrity of my country
uh the payback for all the damages
inflicted by Russian aggression
uh I'm sorry I'm reminding uh I'm
talking about children a lot today but
as a father
uh I would like to emphasize you know
how many how many parents lost their
sons and daughters on the front lines so
what is just peace for them money is
nothing
and no compensations or reparations are
of
uh of no consequence they live by
Revenge I think this is a tremendous
tragedy and the longer the war
lasts the longer this aggression lasts
there will be more parents who live
for the sake of Vengeance or revenge and
I know a lot of people like that
so there can't be any just peace in the
war that was imposed on us by these I I
don't know how to describe that because
we are in the White House and I can't
find the proper language so these
Inhumans I would say
let me respond I I think we have the we
share the exact same vision
and uh that a free independent
prosperous and secure Ukraine is the
vision
we both want this war to end we both
want it to end
and as I've said uh uh it could end a
day if Putin had any dignity at all and
did the right thing and just said pulled
out
but that's not going to happen not going
to happen it's not going to happen now
so what comes next we talked about today
was we're going to continue helping
crane succeed on the battlefield it can
succeed in the battlefield with our help
and the help of our European allies and
others so the if and when President
zielinski is ready to talk with the
Russians he will be able to succeed as
well because he will have won on the
battlefield and uh
um you know I I don't think we should
underestimate the impact this war is
having on Russia and the losses they're
suffering and you saw just I think it
was two days ago Putin saying that this
is much tougher than he thought he
thought he could break NATO he thought
he could break the West he thought he
could break the alliance he thought he
could be welcomed by the Ukrainian
people that were russian-speaking he was
wrong wrong and wrong he continues to be
wrong the sooner he makes it it's clear
that he cannot possibly win this war
that's when the time we have to put this
president in a position to be able to
decide how he wants the war to end
my turn huh
Bliss yeah Phil madly uh manually of CNN
thank you Mr President welcome Mr
President Mr President to start with you
um your advisors often talk about how
important how critically important you
view face-to-face interaction I'm
wondering after spending two plus hours
face to face with President zielinski uh
what you learned or what you took from
the meeting that perhaps you couldn't
glean or learn in the phone calls or
video conferences and somewhat tied to
that was there any discussion related to
the U.S assessment that Russia would not
take escalatory action
now that the Patriots are being sent
will be a patriot battery will be
delivered let me answer the first
question the first part of your question
you know I get kitted for saying that
there's all politics is personal
it's all about looking someone in the
eye and I mean it's sincerely I don't
think there's any any substitute for
sitting down face to face with a friend
or a foe and looking them in the eye
and that's exactly uh what's happened at
this moment we've done that more than
once we're going to continue to do it
and the winner is setting in and Putin
is uh increasingly going after civilian
targets and women and children
orphanages this guy is
well
but uh but he's going to fail and he's
going to fail he's already failed
because he now knows that there's no way
he's ever going to occupy all of Ukraine
there's no way in which he's going to be
accepted by the Ukrainian people and so
uh he's failed in the past and was very
important for him and everyone else to
see the president of zelinski and I are
united two countries together to make
sure he cannot succeed and I think I may
be mistaken but I know I judge every
Leader by the way they what they say to
me the consistency and look him in the
eye this guy has in his to his very soul
is who he says he is it's clear who he
is he's willing to give his life for his
country and all the folks who came with
him today and so I think it's uh he's
important for him to know we are going
to do everything in our power everything
in our power to see that he succeeds
what was the second part of your
question I just asked if you discussed
how the U.S calculated the escalatory
effect of sending a patriot missile
battery to Ukraine I did not discuss
that at all with the with the president
but I we do not it's a defensive system
it's a defensive weapon system it's not
escalatory it's defensive and it's easy
to uh not and we'd love to not have to
have them use it just stop the attacks
president zielinski uh again welcome I
mentioned earlier that you wanted to
make this trip uh for a while now why
now and also can you tell me what you
think the message you are sending to
President Putin is given the fact that
24 hours ago you were on the ground in
the front lines with artillery echoing
behind you and now you find yourself in
the White House standing next to the
president
thank you very much for your question
S2
yeah
what is the message for Putin
I am standing here in the United States
with President Biden on the same Podium
because I respect him as a
person as a president as a human being
for his uh position and for me this is a
historic moment I can send messages to
President Biden for example if it's not
serious you said what's going to happen
after Patriots are installed after that
we will send another signal to President
Biden that we would like to get more
patriots
I'm really sorry that is my appreciation
uh President Putin
in 2019
we had a Normandy meeting in 2019 I
became the president of Ukraine and at
that time we were sending maximum
messages to President Putin telling him
that there shouldn't be a full-scale
Innovation to stop aggression to renew
our territory career territorial
Integrity to find diplomatic solution or
God forbid we should not have a
full-scale war at that time he said it
won't happen he was lying so what kind
of message I can send him after he
actually uh
destroyed our life is destroying our
life he can even go further somewhere
where the Soviet Union stayed before
this so he might want to invade those
territories too I believe that there is
something
mortal about his inadequate approach to
the world why we need to send him a
message he needs to be interested in
getting attention from the world because
he is not a subject of civilized people
he should be interested in trying to
save something of his culture and
history of his country so that's his
problem now
this will be the last question
started U.S officials said that Ukraine
cannot receive Petros because as you
said it might be
um unnecessary escalation and now it is
happening right now today it is
happening
um and now Ukraine desperately needs
more capabilities including long-range
missiles uh attackums maybe I sound
naive but can we make long story short
and give Ukraine all capabilities it
needs and liberate all territories
around us sooner than later thank you
I'm sorry
his answer is yes
[Laughter]
I agree
let me be straightforward with you here
look
the fact is that uh it was important to
remember
that before Russia invaded
we dedicated an enormous amount of
security assistance Ukraine
and uh and we've given Ukraine what they
needed when they needed to defend
themselves
and since the invasion that has resulted
more than 20 billion dollars in terms of
security assistance
just today I approved another 1.8
billion dollars in additional assistance
Ukraine for it to succeed on the
battlefield
and we're focused on working with allies
and partners to generate capability in
four key areas air defense as now as we
know today the Patriot is the best of
that
secondly is to uh and we're looking to
do more
we provided hundreds of advanced
artillery systems and dozens of from
dozens of countries
thirdly we've worked with Partners to
get Ukraine tanks and other armored
vehicles
and fourthly we've announced today
another 200 000 rounds of additional
ammunition
and you say why don't we just give
Ukraine everything there is to give
for two reasons one there's an entire
Alliance that is critical to stay with
Ukraine
and the idea that we would give Ukraine
material that is a fundamentally
different than it's already going there
would have a prospect of breaking up
NATO and breaking up the European Union
and the rest of the world we're going to
give Ukraine what it needs to be able to
defend itself to be able to succeed and
succeed in the battlefield and the other
piece of this is you may recall one of
the reasons why
I have spent well I won't tell you the
calculation but I've spent several
hundred hours face to face
with our European allies and the heads
of state of those countries and making
the case as to why it was overwhelming
in their interest that they continue to
support Ukraine they understand it fully
but they're not looking to go to war
with Russia they're not looking for a
third world war and I think they can all
be avoided by making sure the Ukraine is
able to succeed in the battlefield so
anyway there's more to say but I
probably already said too much
thank you
well thank you all very very much
appreciate your time and attention and
as I said Mr President you don't have to
worry uh we are staying with Ukraine as
long as Ukraine is there thank you all
thank you so much
so much ladies and Gentlemen please
remain in your seats until the official
delegations have departed thank you
thank you
all right
so happens when you're one person
what is that